today on the matt walsh show bank of
america is the latest major corporation
to institute a radical racial
re-education program for its employees
and this is perhaps the worst one yet
also american citizens in afghanistan
according to report have to pay for the
privilege of being evacuated from their
country and jamaicans protest the u.s
embassy for flying a pride flag which is
pretty great also the social media mob
digs up dirt on the new jeopardy host
for some reason because of course we've
got to find some dirt on him and in our
daily cancellation we'll discuss mark
zuckerberg's plan to turn facebook into
a virtual reality experience it's pretty
horrifying all of that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
now a quick word from pearlsource you
know pearlsource if you're looking for
especially guys if you're looking for a
source for a gift for your mom for a
birthday your wife anniversary whatever
it is
uh pearlsource is the way to go at the
pearlsource you get the highest quality
pearl jewelry at up to 70 off retail
prices why because the prosource cuts
out the middleman by eliminating
traditional uh markups by jewelry stores
and selling directly to you and those
markups can be you know three four five
times the markup so you're cutting that
out and you are getting the product
directly they have the largest selection
of pearls available anywhere in the
world and each jewelry piece is custom
made for you the pearl source offers
fast and free two-day shipping on every
single order everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it's ready to be given as
a gift not sure if she'll love your gift
well no worries the pearl source comes
with a no-hassle
60-day money-back guarantee so it is all
risk-free don't overpay for jewelry go
to the pearl source and save up to 70
off of retail prices also the pro source
is having their end of summer sale going
on right now and for a limited time
listeners to my show can get an
additional 15 off the discounted prices
so it's 50 off all off the already
discounted prices go to the
pearlsource.com and enter promo code
wall should check out for 15 off your
entire order if you want fine pearl
jewelry at the best prices online then
go straight to the source the
pearlsource theprosource.com and enter
promo code walsh at checkout
quick note of thanks to all of you who
have helped this show grow tremendously
not long ago i was in my car shouting at
my dashboard filming a show that 12
people were listening to six of them
were in my family
but today um last i checked we've
climbed into the top 40 among all
podcasts just on apple podcast alone
we're top 10 in our category we've also
had incredible growth on youtube spotify
all other platforms all this to say
thank you for making this happen and
also
um i am not satisfied i want more my
theocratic fascist takeover
is n hasn't even begun really so please
if you haven't yet subscribe on apple
podcasts on youtube or both or wherever
whatever platform you like share with
your friends tell the world
our mission is not finished yet all
right as you know the conversation
continues to revolve around the crisis
in afghanistan and perhaps we'll remain
focused there for the foreseeable future
it'll be even easier now for the most
powerful corporations in our country to
get away with imposing their far-left
marxist agenda they were already having
little trouble in that regard but at
least sometimes they would face public
criticism criticism significant enough
in some cases to convince them to change
course i mean when coca-cola instated a
racial indoctrination program they were
eventually forced to put it on pause
pause quote unquote as as they say and
their top lawyer resigned in disgrace
following this massive backlash from the
public
now coca-cola will find other ways i'm
sure to enact their agenda but it's good
that they were held to account for
whatever it's ultimately worth
bank of america on the other hand
has had the good fortune of having its
own radical woke agenda exposed while
everyone's attention is focused on a
country seven thousand miles away but as
this report from journalist chris ruffo
exposes
their racial re-education program is
among the most aggressive and malignant
that we have seen
reading now from the city journal
it says
bank of america corporation has
implemented a racial re-education
program that claims the united states is
a system of white supremacy and
encourages employees to become woke at
work instructing white employees in
particular to decolonize their minds and
seed power to people of color
earlier this year bank of america's
north carolina and charlotte market
president charles bowman announced a new
equity initiative called uni united in
action
in partnership with the united way of
central carolinas according to documents
i have obtained from a whistleblower
this is christopher talking bo boa
executives launched the initiative by
encouraging employees to participate in
their racial equity 21-day challenge a
race training program
funded in part by the bank and built on
the principles of critical race theory
including intersectionality white
privilege white fragility and systemic
racism now
before we go any further i think it's
worth referring back again
to the u.s equal employment opportunity
commission which describes unlawful
workplace harassment and here's what
they say
harassment is a form of employment
discrimination that violates title vii
of the civil rights act of 1964 the age
discrimination in employment act of 1967
and the american with disabilities act
of 1990 harassment is unwelcome conduct
that is based on race color religion sex
national origin older age
beginning at age 40 disability or
genetic information harassment becomes
unlawful where one enduring the
offensive conduct becomes a condition of
continued employment or two the conduct
is severe or pervasive enough to create
a work environment that a reasonable
person would consider intimidating
hostile or abusive
now all of these
racial indoctrination programs are for
this reason blatantly illegal clear
violations of the civil rights act
employees are being singled out by race
labeled in negative ways based on their
race
and often these sessions are mandatory
even when they're not mandatory they
still create an environment that is
clearly intimidating and abusive
when you're pointing to
certain employees by race
and saying they're privileged they're
racist they're this and that
there's a reason why employees leak
these materials to the media
because they feel that this is a hostile
environment and it's an intimidating
environment an abusive environment
none of this even so much as pretends to
be legal
yet companies do it anyway in part
because few of the workers subjected to
this stuff ever decide to actually sue
so let's go back to the report for more
details it gets worse
it says on the program's first day bank
of america teaches employees that the
united states is a racialized society
that uses race to establish and justify
systems of power privilege
disenfranchisement and oppression which
quote gives privileges to white people
resulting in disadvantages to people of
color according to the training program
all whites regardless of one's
socioeconomic class background or other
disadvantages are living a life with
white skin privileges
even children or even children are
implicated in the system of white
supremacy according to the program
materials white toddlers develop racial
biases by ages three and five three to
five and should be actively taught to
recognize and reject the smog of white
privilege
it goes on to say over the next three
days bank of america teaches employees
about intersectionality unconscious bias
microaggressions and systemic racism
the program research quote racism in
america idolizes white physical features
and white values as supreme over those
of others as a result of being part of
the dominant culture whites are more
likely to have more limited imagination
more likely to experience fear anxiety
guilt or shame
more likely to contribute to racial
tension hatred and violence in our homes
communities in the world and
subsequently subsequently uh to react in
broken way broken ways as a result
people of color on the other hand cannot
be racist because racism is used to
justify the position of the dominant
group and to uphold white supremacy and
superiority therefore the discussion
guide claims reverse racism and
discrimination are not possible
okay so
nothing to see here no problem really
just the second largest bank in the
country with two trillion dollars in
assets uh instructing its employees that
members of a certain race are fearful
hateful violent
lack imagination
and give birth to children who become
bigots themselves by the age of three
and it's only white children who are
bigots
who could object to that
well not many people have objected to
this as it turns out
the american bar association certainly
doesn't object as another report also
from this week reveals
this is from the washington free beacon
again this is all just from this week
it says the american bar association is
poised to mandate diversity training and
affirmative action at all of its
accredited law schools a move top legal
scholars say could jeopardize academic
freedom and force schools to violate
federal law the association which
accredits nearly every law school in the
united states is mulling a plan that
would require schools to provide
education to law students on bias
cross-cultural competency and racism
including a mandatory ethics course
instructing students that they have an
obligation to fight racism in the law
schools would also be required to take
effective actions to diversify their
student bodies even when doing so risks
violating a law that purports to
prohibit consideration of race or
ethnicity
now i go back now to that bank of
america discussion
the discussion guide which made the
familiar claim that reverse racism and
reverse discrimination do not exist
now they're correct of course but not
for the reason they think there is no
reverse racism there's just racism
just like there's no such thing as
reverse hatred or reverse jealousy
that's just hatred and jealousy
a racist black person is not reverse
racist he's simply racist
but bank of america remaining dutifully
orthodox and loyal to the crt cult says
that
there cannot be a racist black person
why is that because racism is a tool of
the dominant group
you have to have institutional power in
order to be racist
and black people have no institutional
power they say
and yet even if i agreed with that
definition of racism which i don't
because it's fabricated and ridiculous
yet still this is bank of america we're
talking about
among the racial indoctrination programs
that have been exposed just this week
we have one of the largest banks in the
country and the american bar association
bankers and lawyers
can you get more institutionally
powerful than that
the bankers and lawyers are condemning
whitey
so are the big tech companies almost all
the major corporations hollywood media
academia the government
so when you hear that the institutions
of power are racist against minorities
understand that the person making that
claim
is referring to the institutions of
power
aside from literally all of the
institutions of power
because all of the institutions of power
are fully on the side of the person
making that claim to begin with
the racial warriors on the left
are the system
i mean they are the man now
i think a good rule of thumb is this
you are not a counter culture radical
if you're preaching the same thing
that's preached in bank of america you
know hr seminars
pretty good indication
if what you're saying is
indistinguishable from what you would
hear in an hr seminar at bank of america
then um you're certainly not counter
culture generally speaking
if nearly all of the richest and most
powerful people and institutions in the
country agree with you
and you agree with them
then you may be right or you may be
wrong you're wrong in this case
but whatever you are you certainly are
anything but a rebel
hopefully we could agree
at least with that now let's get to our
five headlines
well gee you know one thing i hate you
know what i hate doing more than
anything in the world i hate going to
the auto parts store i don't know if
i've ever mentioned this to you before
but i think i mentioned many times but i
just hate i hate going into the auto
parts store
there's something about it because it's
hot out
and also you walk into the auto parts
store and i don't know anything about
what i'm doing there so they start
asking me a bunch of questions
i don't know the answer to the quite
it's very embarrassing i run out crying
it's happened so many times
this is why i just stick with
rockauto.com rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store and
having to answer all of those questions
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear why spend you know twice as much on
the same product you'll spend twice as
much for a for a more limited selection
of products why do that when you can
just go to rockauto.com they're a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com right now to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands and specifications
prices you prefer so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck right walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you
so we'll start here back to afghanistan
or at least the people who are trying to
escape afghanistan this is from the
daily wire so according to a report from
the daily caller news foundation the
byte administration is continuing to
tell americans trapped in afghanistan
that if they want to be evacuated out of
the country
they have to pay a cost that could
exceed two thousand dollars
and this comes hours after a
spokesperson for the state department
told the media otherwise
so for the privilege of being evacuated
from that hell hole you have to actually
pay
two thousand dollars or more
uh the daily caller news foundation did
some digging into the online forms that
individuals are required to fill out if
they want to secure a spot on the
repatriation flight the form requires
users to select i understand and wish to
continue with this request for the
following two questions
one repatriation flights are not free
all passengers will need to reimburse
the us government for the flights
a promissory note for the full cost of
the flight which may exceed 2 000 per
person must be signed by each adult
passenger before boarding
and also loan repayments
while my passport will not be cancelled
u.s citizens who have signed a loan
agreement for repatriation may not be
eligible for a new passport until the
loan is repaid
so
the federal government as it stands
right now according to this report
they're not willing to spring for the 2
000 bucks to get these american citizens
out of the country if if they even get
them out of the country to begin with
because let's keep in mind
um
the first part of that trip is they're
on their own for to get to the airport
which right now is seems to be basically
impossible because it's surrounded by
the taliban
so if you can manage on your own as an
american citizen to get to the airport
the buying administration is not going
to help you
not going to guarantee your safety you
could die that's that's up to you that's
your problem the bite administration
says if you get there
then we're gonna give you a bill for two
thousand dollars just to bring you home
pretty uh
it seems like they're
being very conscious of the of the
budget apparently
very budget-conscious
except that
i mean what are we doing here
we've been handing out checks left and
right for thousands of dollars to
americans here who for no reason
just just giving it to them
as a reward for the fact that there was
a pandemic it doesn't matter if you know
some of them lost their job but even if
you didn't lose your job you still get
the check
canceling
rent spending trillions of dollars
on these kinds of entitlement programs
and yet the federal government
can't
manage to come up with to scrounge
together two thousand dollars a person
to get these people home
from afghanistan
and i mean why is that well it's pretty
obvious that
handing out these kinds of entitlement
checks to americans here
is politically useful
um but as
up to this point they haven't seen a lot
of political
use in in doing the same for the people
that are trapped in afghanistan maybe
that will change though
i would have to think that their
political calculations are changing
all right moving on here's something um
pretty interesting the u.s embassy in
jamaica is
among the many embassies across the
world right now that's flying a pride
flag
we know even the embassy in kabul was
flying a pride flag which we could
assume at this point has been taken down
well they put one up in jamaica and some
jamaicans are not
happy about that
they they say that
they don't want the pride flag flying in
fact they say that it's cultural
imperialism and i think they kind of
make a good point let's listen to them
and as you might be able to see in the
background the u.s embassy continues to
fly the lgbt flag lesbian gay bisexual
transgender flag
in breach of the vienna convention
articles 31e article 20 and article 41
right they are being hostile towards our
laws our culture and our own democratic
system instead of flying the jamaican
flag for iman's dependence they have
decided to fly that flag and that is an
insult to our country philippa davies
advocacy officer for the jamaica
coalition for a healthy society says the
flag represents life practices that
threatens the jamaican culture and the
teachings of the bible she says it also
affects the health of the society you
have to understand what that multicolor
flag represents it represents
normalizing perverse sexual behaviors
and lifestyle choices behaviors and
lifestyles that lead to disease and
death our christian duty is to speak the
truth in love protesters say they have
been peacefully protesting that the flag
be taken down since the day it was
raised but are shocked it remains on the
flagpole up to man's dependence week
efforts to contact the u.s consulate and
a member of the lgbtq group on friday
proved futile however the protesters say
they will continue to stand against the
flying of the rainbow colored flag
describing it as a symbol of disrespect
on jamaican soil article 20 specifically
says the only flag that should fly is
their national flag
the lgbt flag is not their national flag
their own people have not agreed to that
at all okay
well
they raised some good points i would say
and there's no response to that from the
left has no response all they could do
is ignore this kind of thing
um because if they were to
meet that head-on and offer a response
the response would be something like
well
this is not your value system but it
should be
this should be your value system
because of course i mean
we're so used to it by now
uh that that maybe we don't stop and
reflect on just how crazy this actually
is that u.s embassies are flying any
flag other than the american flag
i don't even care what flag it is
why are you flying why is the american
government flying any flag
anywhere
other than the american flag
the federal government should be flying
no flag except the american flag
should be showing no loyalty to anything
but
its own country
and then to consider what that flag is
flag showing pride in certain sexual
orientations
this is what our embassies are doing
a flag to show pride in
homosexuality or transgenderism
no matter
no matter how you even feel about that
why why is the ameri why is a federal
government
why does the federal government have
anything to say about that
at home or especially abroad
it's insane
and then meanwhile we're flying this
flag
um
to promote a value system
that many americans don't share to begin
with
but promoting it in countries
uh that certainly don't share it and if
if they're flying the american flag
anywhere that is not a western country i
mean anywhere
then they are promoting this value
system they're imposing this value
system on people who do not share it and
don't want it
so what are you gonna do
are you going to i mean
someone should go down there
and explain to these people no you don't
yeah you you don't believe in this this
is not your value system but it should
be we will tell you what your value
system should be
no on the left when they worry about
cultural appropriation
or
cultural imperialism you hear these
kinds of phrases from them
but they're worried about i mean there
was there was some uh
ridiculous woman i think some journalist
this past week
who was upset on twitter because a white
woman had uh had made a cookbook
on on how to make dumplings she had made
a dumpling cookbook
and there was some leftist who was upset
about this
i said what is this white woman
making a cookbook about dumplings for
well probably she made the couple the
dumpling cookbook because she's good at
making dumplings and shows she had some
advice on how to do that
but that is cultural imperialism
according to the left
to make a food item
that
arguably originates somewhere aside from
the continental united states
that's the kind of appropriation and
cultural
imperialism they're worried about
meanwhile we're overseas flying pride
flags
trying to impose this value system
on people who do not want it
all right this is from pew research
center
kind of concerning i would say it says
amid rising concerns over misinformation
online including surrounding the kova 19
pandemic especially vaccines americans
are now a bit more open to the idea of
the u.s government taking steps to
restrict false information online and a
majority of the public continues to
favor technology companies taking such
action according to a new research pew
research center survey roughly half of
u.s adults 48 percent
now say the government should take steps
to restrict false information
even if it means losing some freedom to
access and publish content
according to the survey of 11 000 adults
conducted july 26 through august 8th
that's up from 39
in 2018 which is a pretty large jump
now of course
all the familiar grains of salt have to
be taken here
because this is a pew survey
but half of the country having this view
sounds about right to me not not too
surprising but it is pretty disturbing
because what you have among these
americans not only is uh
are they not valuing their own freedom
but just an incredible amount of
stupidity
incredibly stupid
that they haven't
thought this through at all they
answered the survey question
but they haven't they haven't they
haven't thought about this beyond
surface level
you want the government to be invo to be
in charge of restricting false
information
okay what does that mean it means the
government is deciding
the government is now the arbiter of
what is true
that's how the question should be
phrased
do you think that the the government
should be the arbiter of truth
do you trust the government
to tell you what is true and what isn't
should the government be though should
they be the ones to decide what is true
and what isn't
that's really the question
and these morons which would include
according to this survey anyway half of
the country
are perfectly willing to give that power
to the government
meanwhile many of these same people
would tell you with a straight face
that at least for the previous four
years our government has been run by a
fascist dictator who's literally worse
than hitler
that's the kind of mistrust they have of
the government on one hand
that they think it's within the realm of
possibility for a
you know a hitlerian dictator to take
charge of it and that that was the case
for the past four years and yet they
also trust the government to tell them
to decide what is true and what isn't
because this should be obvious but we
have to keep repeating it
you know the issue one of the many
issues with the government
censoring and restricting misinformation
or so-called false information
is that someone has to decide has to
decide what is false and what's
misinformation and you're giving that
power to the government
all right moving on there have been a
series of attacks in chicago by roving
gangs of teenagers and we've got a local
news report on one of the latest attacks
a woman was beaten by a group of teens
mostly boys it would seem
and she's in critical condition now
she's got a fractured skull lacerations
lots of damage
here's the report on that
a rideshare driver gave us this video
look closely at the intersection as the
driver pulls up to the red light here at
jackson and state around 11 30 saturday
night you can see the woman is being
dragged
you can also hear her screaming
a man in a white shirt tries to help her
he starts to fight with the teens that
are attacking her as the woman gets up
and starts to walk away watch as one of
the teens grabs what appears to be a bag
that was left on the street he calmly
walks away with it the woman gets up and
tries to walk
she stumbles then collapses to the
ground the man in the white shirt again
comes to help her as some of the teens
ride away on divi bikes as the ride
share driver goes through the
intersection look to your right
some of the teens with bikes are making
their way down the stairs to a cta
platform this incident is one of five
attacks on people in the loop between
saturday and monday police say in each
case groups of three to 12 teens go up
to victims and demand to have their
belongings
the victims are then surrounded and
beaten by the teens using their hands
and feet until the victim gives up their
property
nothing new there in chicago
eventually maybe
we all see these stories all the time in
places like chicago and baltimore and
every other major city in the country
um this kind of violence that
yeah ostensibly they're doing it to rob
the woman which is bad enough on its own
but it's pretty clear that it's it's not
really even about
taking her belongings
i mean that would be that would be
horrible that would be better than what
is the reality and the reality is that
they're just doing it for fun
and uh
the the taking the purse is sort of a
prize at the end of it
icing on the cake for them really
really it's simply the thrill of
victimizing an innocent person and
beating them for the sake of it
eventually maybe we'll get around asking
the question
of
how are we raising kids
what's going on
in a child's life and these are not
these are not children these are you
know i would call them young adults
but what's going on in a child's life
that they would turn into that
i mean when you look at cities across
the country and you see
these
violent thugs
with with just no
conscience at all
committing these acts of brutality and
barbarism for the fun of it what how
does that happen how do you end up with
that
but these are the conversations we can't
have so usually we're just gonna we're
gonna talk about if there was a gun
involved there's a reason we're not
hearing about this at all in the in the
mainstream media i mean the local media
is talking about mainstream media
national media is not talking about it
because there's no gun involved here
they just use their fists and whatever
other object whatever other blunt
instruments they have around to uh beat
unsuspecting women with
if there's a gun then they'll talk about
the gun and
how did it end up that these uh these
kids have got their hands on on a gun
but even then we're not going to talk
about well it's okay they got their
hands on a gun what what prompted them
to use it in that way
you had a case
last week i remember what city it was in
i want to say it was maybe new york
and this was caught on camera there was
a fight outside of a shoe store about
shoes
and one of the employees from the shoe
store came out to try to disperse things
courageously really and he got she was
shot and killed
you did hear a little bit about that
because of the gun and so we're told
well he had a gun
how did this young man get this gun
gun violence is a big problem
that's not really my question
my question is okay he had the gun
why would he want to use it like that
what's going on in his mind
that would make him want to kill another
person over a fight over shoes
that's the real question that's that's
that's the discussion we simply can't
have apparently
i also want to know what's going on the
minds of these people this is from the
daily wire it says newly named jeopardy
host mike richards is under fire for
resurfaced comments he made that some
critics are calling sexist and racist
pop culture outlet the ringer first
reported thursday that between 2013 2014
as the host of the podcast random
richards referred to his female co-host
as a
and i'm
quoting now
as a booth hoe
a booth
booth statute
and booth [ __ ]
um
and said women in one-piece bathing
suits look really frumpy and overweight
in other episodes richards made
disparaging racial remarks referring to
jewish people he said of a woman's
facial features ixnay on the o's nay
she's not an uj
in a separate incident when his co-host
described issues she was having with her
apartment
he asked if she lived in haiti adding
doesn't it sound like that like the
urine smell the women in the mumu the
stray cats
and there were other comments like that
that he made on his this was a podcast
that no one's ever heard of from uh from
about eight years ago
and what we're told is that these
comments uh resurfaced they just kind of
bubbled to the surface on their own that
happens sometimes
but that's not actually what happened of
course there's no resurfacing
someone had to go and dig through this
podcast from eight years ago that no
one's ever heard of or knew existed
to find these
comments and that raises the question of
why
what's the point
the comments he made and i don't know
anything about mike richards i don't
care who hosts jeopardy
um it's not alex trebek so there's no
one that can fill those shoes
unfortunately
for me and and i used to be a big
jeopardy fan but for me it's lost almost
all of its charm now that alex trebek is
gone so i don't care who owes it doesn't
matter i have no interest in defending
mike richards what do i care i'm sure
he's already uh you know i'm sure he's
already broken down onto his knees and
apologized
um
and if he hasn't yet then i'm sure he
will that's usually the way these things
go
so it doesn't matter much to me the
comments he made in the in the podcast
eight years ago were they objectionable
yeah
but what's going why would someone had
to
hear the news that some guy named mike
richards is gonna be the host of
jeopardy
and then say i'm gonna comb through this
guy's past i'm going to go through hours
and hours of tape
and i'm going to find
i'm going to find something
i'm going to see if this guy has ever
said or done anything bad so that i can
destroy him
because he's going to be the host of
jeopardy
now i understand if someone is running
for political office that's the way the
game is played
the people on the other side
his rivals want to destroy him i get
that that's the way that goes that's the
way it's always gone in politics
this is about the most apolitical
position a person could possibly hold
the host of jeopardy
so what would compel you to want to go
digging for that in the first place
well it's just this is the reaction now
that a lot of people have you you see
someone in the news
and they're kind of rise their head is
rising above the the pack a little bit
something good is happening to them
this guy gets to be the host of jeopardy
i'm sure it's a lifelong dream of his
maybe not but it's a it's a big deal for
him
and so the immediate reaction
from a lot of people in this diseased
culture of ours is to say let's try to
destroy that guy
because i don't know him i got nothing
personally against him he's never done
anything to me but let's ruin his life
let's not just take his job away but for
the crime
of being given this opportunity and
having good fortune
befall him for that crime for the crime
of being a fortunate person we are just
going to ruin him
and that's what they've done
it is uh
you know if if that's your instinct to
do that you need to look deeply within
yourself
to figure out what's going on in your
own heart
that that would even occur to you
i heard the news that mike richards was
gonna be a jeopardy host it never
occurred to me to wonder about offensive
things he said in the past i i probably
would have assumed that he said
offensive things in the past because
everybody has
never would occur to me to go check
and if i had checked for some reason and
i discovered that you know what i would
have done i would have told anybody
because i'm not looking to just destroy
people for no reason
if that's how you get your rocks off if
that's if that's how you if that's your
form of of recreation entertainment you
need to look within yourself and inside
your own soul all right finally it's
been a while since we've played a crazy
person on tick tock but we're going to
do this this is a
preschool teacher
talking about her experiences um on the
first day of preschool and let's uh
let's just watch
story time
this has been my first year in preschool
with a class of my own teaching
alongside another queer neurodivergent
educator and we have been rocking our
two's class we've been talking about
gender and skin color and consent and
empathy and our bodies and autonomy it's
been fabulous
but our teaching team is shifting and a
new person is being onboarded someone
with many years of experience so today
at the lunch table when the topic of
gender and genitals came up one of our
students plainly looked up and said well
i'm a girl today but i know that teacher
co isn't
no they're envy
and the look on the incoming teacher's
face was priceless
she was shocked in a good way and she
just looked around at the two of us and
said this class is incredible and i am
so impressed
they're really trying to make
neurodivergent happen aren't they
i'm hearing that phrase more and more
now yeah i don't mean to discriminate at
all but you know that's that's that's
not that's not who i am that's not me
but
if you
notice that your child's preschool
teacher
has five piercings on each ear and a
nose ring
that's a problem
really the nose ring at all
these are these are the worn these are
the red flags and the warning signs you
have to look out for
or really we could take a step back
we step back farther than that because
the actual warning sign is that it's a
it's a public school preschool
at this point if you're sending your
your child to preschool at all in a
public school environment
then um
that that is
an unjustifiable decision at this point
i would say
you just cannot send
now you know how i feel about public
school in general
and i i don't think we should be sending
our kids to public school at all but at
least if it's something like an older
kid a kid in high school or something
you know you could there's a possibility
that they're going to have enough moral
and intellectual formation at that point
where they can withstand the
indoctrination that's being foist upon
them
also there's at least the possibility
although i know that teenagers are
notoriously not very forthcoming with
information about themselves and their
experiences even so there's the
possibility that you could sit down and
talk to your teenager and say what
happened at school today you can have a
conversation you can hear about these
things but
you're sending your three-year-old
in
you're not going to hear about any of
this
you can't talk to them
they're not going to tell you about any
of this stuff
i mean they they might mention it they
might mention something in passing
that raises your antenna
but for the most part you're probably
not going to hear about it
um
and also they are totally susceptible
they are they are 100 susceptible to
whatever their preschool teacher tells
them
so when this weirdo this degenerate
freak sits down with your three-year-old
and says let's talk about our bodies
whatever comes out of her mouth yet your
child is 100 susceptible to it
he has no defenses at all
you send your three-year-old into public
school
you're this is an act of absolute
complete trust in the system you are
trusting
that nobody will take advantage of your
child's innocence
and vulnerability
to turn them into something that you
don't even recognize you're trusting
that and what i'm saying is you cannot
trust the system
you can't trust the system at all
you certainly can't trust it entirely
and absolutely which is what you do when
you drop your three-year-old off in the
building you say hey okay i'll be back
in a few hours
just don't do it it's not worth it
it's not worth it
now we're going to check in with a new
sponsor we're very excited about super
beats you know it's it's hard to
get all the nutrients that you need to
get every single day
especially if you're busy i mean there's
you might eat plenty of food we all
probably eat too much food but are you
getting the actual nutrients that you
need from that food a lot of us aren't
and that's why you need superb super
beets heart chews combines non-gmo beets
with a special ingredient grape seed
extract that is unique to super beets
heart chews grape seed extract has been
the focus of scientific research for
years due to its high concentration of
antioxidants which supports
cardiovascular health and overall
wellness i don't really know what an
antioxidant is to be honest but from all
the from all the hype i understand that
it's pretty important to have the grape
seed extract used in super beets heart
shoes has been clinically shown to be
two times as effective as supporting
normal blood pressure as a healthy
lifestyle alone
and just two delicious chews a day gives
the blood pressure support you need and
the energy that you want and need as
well so do what i did and support your
heart health with delicious super beats
heart shoes get your super beat heart
shoes today at superbeats.com walsh and
then you buy two bags they'll throw in
the third for free so you want to take
advantage of that that's superbeats.com
walsh
all right let's move now to reading the
comments this is from john smith says i
think the hardest time matt has is
thinking about something that he says is
when he has to come up with a different
pronunciation for every individual every
time he mentions them
well jan smythe i really don't know what
you're even talking about rhys
richardson says i'm getting married on
saturday i'm aiming for five
five wives or children
i hope you mean children and five is a
great number
um violin girl says you don't seem to
have a problem with killing animals so
why would you judge people who choose
abortion
well violent girl uh it's because
p
people
are different
from animals
so it's for the same reason let me try
to explain it this way
have you ever in your life
been driving down the road
and seen a roadkill on the side of the
road have you ever had that experience i
bet you have you've seen a dead deer or
a raccoon or a skunk or something and uh
how do you react to that when you see
that dead animal on the side of the road
you probably don't think anything at all
you just keep driving
maybe at most you think oh that's sad
poor deer and then you go about your day
if you were driving along and you saw a
dead person on the side of the road
you would have a very different reaction
right i mean aside from the fact that
you would call the police hopefully
but that would be a deeply traumatic
experience for you
and it would hit you on a much deeper
level that's something you would
remember for the rest of your life can
you remember specific incidents of
roadkill that you saw
um in fact we refer to animals as
roadkill
if you saw a dead person on the side of
the road would you would you call it
dead person roadkill ah there's some
roadkill and just keep driving no
you would be
traumatized by that
you'd be very deeply shaken by it you'd
remember it for the rest of your life
the time you saw a dead person on the
side of the road
so why is that
you you come up with an answer to that
question and you'll have my answer on
this
i think the answer is that
in most cases you value human life more
than you you value animal life
it's just that you make an exception for
unborn human life
and what i'm saying is that there's no
reason to make that exception
because unborn human life is still human
life and if you have judged that human
life is more valuable than animal life
which you have and i know you have
then you should make the same judgment
for unborn human life that's my point
uh jared says you're right matt a
nation's happiness success and pride are
totally correlated to the amount of
children they have like niger which is
at seven kids per woman they've had lots
of national successes since their
independence in 1958 they've had five
military coups and it's yearly and it's
uh
yearly is dead last or close to it in
the human development index totally
great logic also check out the next
highest uh countries in birth rates all
of the uber patriotic high achieving
countries like angola mali chad uganda
and south sudan
uh yes jared very clever
i mean you can indeed provide many
examples of third world countries and
failed states where people have lots of
kids and yet remain third world
countries and failed states nothing i
said yesterday contradicts that
what i would like to know though is if
you can provide an example
of a country that experienced a
precipitous decline in the birth rate
and then went on to flourish like never
before
that was my question
where has a drop in fertility led to led
to national success and prosperity
can you come up with an example of that
and i think you probably can
because
generally when us when a civilization
gives up on the future
and when you when you've dropped below
replacement level
when your fertility rate has dropped
below replacement level that means that
collectively you've given up on the
future
um and when that happens that's not a
sign of a of a healthy civilization
that's not a sign of a civilization with
a future because it's given up on the
future
um
oj says matt an iphone and a puppy is
not nearly as expensive as a family
children cost hundreds of thousands to
raise responsible people understand that
they can't afford it
who are these people that can't afford
having a kid who are they
who are the people who can't afford kids
because you know i know families
with
single-income families
where the mother stays home
six seven eight kids or more and they're
not making
more than 80 or 90 000 a year at most
for all those kids i know plenty of
families like that
i know families that make a lot less
than that
and have
more kids than i do
sometimes significantly more
so what is this stuff about i can't
afford a kid what do you what do you
mean exactly
you know i see people all the time who
live in nice you know apartments and
they've got all they've got all the
latest consumer electronics they've
they're living very comfortably
and they say they can't afford having a
kid
meanwhile people who have less money
than
them have kids and also manage to live
comfortably how does that work
because it like i said yesterday it's
about priorities
okay children
and it's also about just prop things
like proper budgeting children don't
come with a price tag
the idea and i hear this a lot that uh
well the average child costs whatever
whatever number they give you now it's
like 300 000 cost 300 000 to get a child
from you know age zero up to 18. that's
absurd that would mean that you know a
middle-class family with four or five
kids would have would spend it like over
a million dollars raising those kids
meanwhile they might not even earn a
million dollars in that time
what we're being told is that to have a
large fan by by your estimation to have
a large family and by large i mean like
four kids or more you would have to be a
millionaire to afford it
and yet i'm willing to guess right now
that not only is it not true that all
families of that all large families are
millionaires i would guess
that
almost every large family is is not a
millionaire family
no generally when you look at the higher
income brackets they have fewer kids
so there seems to be a disconnect here
you're assuming it's just not possible
you can't afford kids our kids are
prohibitively expensive and yet you look
throughout the the world and billions of
people manage to do it
and they're not all living in poverty
many of them will manage to do it and
live very comfortably
because it's about proper budgeting it's
about having a priorities straight
and yeah i mean you may have to make
some sacrifices
rather than having seven tvs in the
house maybe you only maybe you have to
make do with three
you know rather than getting the latest
iphone as soon as it comes out
you know maybe you only maybe you have
to wait like maybe every third iphone
you you get you get the upgrade
something like that
uh maybe instead of going overseas on a
vacation you got to settle with the
continental united states i mean these
are the kind of sacrifices that families
have to make
all right jordan says marriage is a no
from me man western women are lost
beyond hope
and another comment from marina who says
would love to have lots of babies but
just can't find a good man well
reena meet jordan jordan meet reena
you got i hear this all the time men
complaining they can't find a good woman
women complaining they can't find a good
man i understand that it probably is
difficult but they are out there
and we just made a connection right here
in the youtube comment section on the
matt walsh show
love is in the air
you know if you like to stay well read
and informed then i think the daily
wires reader pass readers passes is what
you need it's right up your alley and
the good thing is that it's only four
bucks a month okay the daily wire
readers pass unlocks exclusive editorial
content that unpacks trending political
and cultural topics penned by everyone
from candace owens to dan crenshaw plus
you can catch our latest analysis pieces
which go up every single day uh and we
also have readers pass collection where
we organize everything
um they've got current
collections include the hunter biden
files and blm the organization behind a
movement
you can get all of this again
i think the headline here is for just
four dollars a month so go to
dailywire.com right now sign up for the
readers pass and
as you all well know the sweet baby gang
is an exclusive club that only my
listeners are a part of
uh if you're one of the gang
then i have excellent news and i say it
you know only my listeners are part of
the sweet petty gang that's true
but not not even all the listeners are
part of the sweet baby gang okay it is
it's a more exclusive club than that
um and here's the excellent news we are
in need of a sweet baby gang anthem and
this is going to be something that
just encapsulates everything that sweet
baby gang represents and stands for
whatever that happens to be and so we
are what i've been saying is we we're
looking for for the sweet baby gang is
looking for its own francis scott key
we're looking for someone who can make
our anthem
that we will stand for
hand on heart there's gonna be no
kneeling for this anthem at all um and
that's why the daily wire is right now
opening up submissions submissions have
been opened up all you have to do is go
to dailywire.com
sbg uh what you want to do is record
your uh your your video record the song
do it put it on youtube and then submit
the link to dailywire.com spg
submissions end on august 25th so you've
got a few days left to do that and then
we're going to judge all of these songs
in sort of american idol style and
decide who has the ultimate sweet baby
gang anthem so again that's
dailywire.com
uh now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
there's a made-for-tv movie from my
childhood called not quite human and as
i recall it was about a creepy
middle-aged man who builds a robot that
looks like a boy and then adopts him as
a son
and the robot is mostly lifelike but his
true android nature sometimes comes
comes through in the way that he speaks
and the way that he moves
it was a great film a real classic of
the genre and by genre i mean 80s made
for tv movies about robots this had to
be in like the top 10 of that category
anyway you may be wondering why i'm
telling you about this and i'm sort of
wondering about that myself i think the
main reason
is that i can never figure out who mark
zuckerberg reminds me of exactly until i
remembered not quite human he is like a
form of ai an android that almost passes
for a real boy a robotic pinocchio you
might say
and i wouldn't normally make fun of him
for this after all you know he can't
help it if he was assembled in a
laboratory in some mad scientist
basement somewhere but the problem is
that zuckerberg wants to turn all of us
into robots just like him
and he so far had enormous success in
that regard and it's only going to get
worse from here
so facebook along with the other tech
giants plans to move away from
traditional social media
and into the world of virtual reality
zuckerberg is now building what he
describes as a metaverse
a word he takes directly from a
dystopian sci-fi book which is a little
too on the nose for my taste an article
in the conversation has this it says
mark zuckerberg wants to reinvent
facebook he's been telling analysts and
journalists that he wants the company to
lead the way to a completely different
internet he said quote in the coming
years i expect people will transition
from seeing us primarily as a social
media company to seeing us as a
metaverse company in many ways the
metaverse is the ultimate expression of
social technology the term metaverse is
used to describe the vision whereby the
internet will evolve into a virtual
world it foresees the internet as a 3d
virtual living space where individuals
dip in and out interacting with one
another in real time many in silicon
valley still view the metaverse as the
future for example google is heavily
invested in augmented reality which is
where you use technology to look at the
real world but with digital 3d objects
layered on top and rumors swirled that
apple is building products like glasses
for experiencing virtual spaces but
facebook appears the most committed to
all through this new vision in his quest
to turn facebook into a metaverse
company zuckerberg is seeking to build a
system where people move between virtual
reality
augmented reality and even 2d devices
using realistic avatars of themselves
where appropriate
here they will work socialize share
things
and have other experiences
now one need not strain too much to
imagine what those other experiences
might be i'll say only that porn sites
are also working on building their own
virtual reality universes so maybe you
connect the dots there but as the
article suggests
um zuckerberg is ahead of the game and
has already come up with his first
metaverse application in an effort to as
he says help us to be a part of and
inside of the internet
he's come up with a with something
called horizon workrooms which is a
virtual reality office space
where you can have meetings with your
co-workers
inside the metaverse
so think of it like zoom
except a thousand times worse
here is zuckerberg on cbs this morning
giving a demonstration of the metaverse
workrooms is used on facebook's oculus
quest 2 virtual reality headsets
once inside you can customize your own
avatar
mark i'm in
all right welcome oh my god you've got
freckles on your nose i have freckles in
real life too so i'm you know trying to
do the best
do you like my glasses i like it in here
your avatar looks great this is my first
virtual reality interview how about you
mine too my first virtual reality
interview too you know we're very
optimistic
that
in five years from now
people are going to be able to live
where they want and work from wherever
they want they want but but are going to
be able to feel present as if they're
together when they're doing that do you
have a favorite feature to use in here
yeah something that you think is very
cool
yeah i mean there are a couple of things
that i really like i mean one is that
you can just dynamically change the
layout of the room so you know i mean
here you know i can we're in a a room
layout that's that's designed for
conversation i can switch us really
quickly so now we're um we're in a
presentation setting yes so that's
pretty neat it might be in the middle
yeah and then you know check this out i
can i can basically go
and um
and and go stand at the white board
and um
wow it's like brainstorming just like in
a normal meeting that you would have
been in
well that is truly horrifying many
problems spring immediately to mind
first of all
what if jeffrey toobin shows up to your
metaverse meeting
i mean he's bad enough on zoom now
imagine being trapped in virtual reality
with him also who in god's name wants to
be more fully immersed in a work meeting
who's ever been sitting on a zoom call
and said to themselves man this is great
but i just wish i could be literally
trapped inside this call right now in
the computer with all these people
the whole advantage of zoom is that you
don't have to pay attention or actually
be physically near anyone
now that's being taken away
and zuckerberg says that it's great
because now you can attend meetings from
anywhere on earth hooray that's
wonderful so even if you're on vacation
in fiji your boss back in new jersey can
still call you into the conference room
for a meeting
that's supposed to be a good thing
you know one of the problems with zoom
and social media and the internet
generally
is it won't allow us to get the hell
away from each other and that makes this
problem
this makes that problem i think a lot
worse not to mention what if your boss
calls you in to fire you
can you imagine getting fired by your
employer's cartoon avatar
talk about insult injury and speaking of
the cartoon avatar why exactly would you
want to make it look exactly like
yourself right down to the facial
blemishes if there's any advantage to
this kind of thing wouldn't it be that
you can build a better version of
yourself
more interesting version of the world as
well
this is one of the many downsides of
living in a country run by these tech
nerds i mean they're all genius
iq billionaires but
they have very little imagination so
zuckerberg can create a virtual reality
world
but he makes it look like a conference
room on the ninth story of an office
building in cincinnati
if we're gonna do this meta universe
thing why wouldn't you have your meeting
on like a a moon of jupiter or inside a
volcano or
in the jungle during the jurassic period
you could do all of that you might as
well make it interesting if we're going
to do this
but going back to what i just said
before i said that one of the problems
with the internet is that it won't allow
us to get the hell away from each other
and that's true
it becomes weirdly claustrophobic and
exhausting because we're all in constant
contact with each other all the time
with no space to breathe
even the simple act of carrying a phone
around all the time is oppressive
constantly at the beck and call of
anyone who happens to have our phone
number when i was a child and you kids
out there you you'll find this hard to
believe but
when i was a child
if you wanted to talk to somebody on the
phone
or contact them at all
and they weren't physically at their
house
then you simply wouldn't be able to
contact them
you you would have to call and leave a
message and wait for them to respond
and it might take a few days
people would walk around in the world
every day
with nothing in their pocket but a
wallet and maybe keys
you were forced to if you can believe it
you were forced to actually acknowledge
and interact with your immediate
environment and the people within it
and if two people were out there in the
world somewhere far away from you having
a conversation there would be no way for
you to intrude into it you couldn't call
you couldn't send a text
they're over there living their lives
and you were here and all you could do
was be here in this place that you are
with no way to
escape it except to you know
be to physically travel to another place
and sometimes and this i know you won't
believe
but sometimes
you would do this thing called nothing
and what i mean is
maybe you were sitting in a waiting room
getting your oil changed or at the
dentist and there were no good magazines
or you know nothing that you were
interested in on tv
and maybe nobody was around you who you
felt like talking to so you would just
sit there
and think can you imagine that
you just like sit have you ever done
this i know it's like people of a
certain age have probably never done
this in their lives but you just you sit
in the chair
that's all you do you just sit there
and you think about things
and thinking you know this is the if i
have to explain what thinking is
thinking is this thing that people used
to do
before google started doing it for them
so all this to say
the internet makes it so that we can't
escape other people
except for those people who are actually
physically present with
it keeps us connected to strangers and
social media mob and co-workers and
other assorted malcontents
but it becomes this complete inversion
of priorities because the thing that
grabs our attention
is the thing which is
which we are farthest away from
we become immersed in the universe but
not the room we're sitting in
now with virtual reality and augmented
reality this will only get worse
think about augmented reality
now they want to augment
even that room that you're sitting in
which you were already mostly ignoring
they want to facilitate
all of our human interactions including
the in-person face-to-face interactions
what few of them we have anymore
we'll reach a point where i'm sure you
know people are going to be sitting in a
physical conference room with each other
all together and all wearing those dumb
looking headsets so that they can
interact with the cartoon versions of
each other
we are slowly giving up on flesh and
blood human existence melting into the
internet
becoming a part of it
as zuckerberg says
says he wants us to be a part of the
internet
a hellish dystopian
vision
that he openly says that's his plan
soon we'll all be soulless machines like
himself not quite human
like the 80s tv movies tried to warn us
but we didn't listen because we never do
and so it's probably futile now to say
this but i will anyway
while i still can
mark zuckerberg you are of course
canceled
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great weekend everybody see you on
monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin